now we turn to President Biden's
handling of items marked classified even
more were found in President Biden's
house in Wilmington Delaware after the
president's lawyers invited the FBI to
search it on Friday some of those
materials date back to Mr Biden's Senate
days more than 14 years ago Ed O'Keefe
is at the White House Ed good morning
Nate good morning to you the president's
attorney says the latest batch amounts
to six more items with classification
markings for now a total of between 25
and 30 documents and an assign of how
this investigation may continue to
stretch out a source familiar with the
probe tell CBS News investigators are
considering searching other locations
Mr President bipartisan questions and
concern how serious are they
um why were they taken did anyone have
access to them this is a real critical
question to all this why did he have
these documents to begin with as even
more items with classified markings were
found in President Biden's Delaware home
Friday after his personal attorneys and
White House council's Office agreed to
an FBI search over nearly 13 hours
investigators reviewed personally
handwritten notes files papers binders
memorabilia to-do lists schedules and
reminders going back decades the
president's attorney says the FBI took
six items consisting of documents with
classification markings and surrounding
materials some for when Mr Biden served
in the Senate others for when he was
vice president and with no need for a
search warrant Ally say that's a big
difference from the search for
classified documents at former president
Donald Trump's Florida home which did
require a warrant in the end we will see
this was just an inadvertent matter of
filing in sharp contrast to his
predecessor but notably other senior
Democrats are taking a more critical
stance because it's not supposed to
happen whether it was a the fault of a
staffer or attorney it makes no
difference the elected official Bears
ultimate responsibility it's just hard
to believe that that in the United
States of America we have a former
president and a current president
they're basically in the same situation
how does this happen
we should point out the bidens were not
at their Wilmington Delaware home at the
time of the search on Friday they spent
the weekend at their other Delaware home
in Rehoboth Beach now today the top
Republican on the house oversight
committee says he'll be reaching out to
the Secret Service asking for any and
all documentation of who might have been
visiting the Biden's residences and
potentially could have had access to
those documents Nate
and while all this is playing out you
have new reporting on a big staff
shake-up in the West Wing that's right
CBS News has confirmed that President
Biden's Chief of Staff Ron Clane is
preparing to step down in the coming
weeks at some point after the State of
the Union next month he has served in
the role for a little more than two
years as most Chiefs of Staff do so
who's up next well we're told it's the
former policies are for covid-19
response Jeff zeitz he was responsible
for coordinating the administration's
response to the pandemic which he did
until stepping down last spring you can
expect zeins will focus on essentially
keeping the trains running on time and
implementing all that big legislation
that was passed over the last two years
a big priority for the president Zion
steps into the role though as somebody
who knows the president pretty well Nate
as always Ed you're on top of it thank
you